[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
Да ничего
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
Привет с Японии
Все классно Супер да первый день в
Япония сегодня много мероприятий Так что
предвкушение чего-то такого японского
Ждем только начало начинается очень
супер шикарно Япония первый раз страна
восходящего солнца всю жизнь мечтал об
этом и вот наконец это мечта благодаря
команде
Я надеюсь что хорошо проведем время
отдохнем увидим многое
такие
дисциплины порядка
передовых технологий узнаем много чего
сегодня была прогулка общение
[музыка]
он может например японец идти по саду и
сказать что-то в этом году рано клен там
листья опали рядом который идет человек
и думает почему-то он сказал наверное
немного и приносит ему накидывает на
плечи там плащики что-то такое то есть
обязанность по понятию мыслей лежит на
слушающих у восточных людей а у западных
обязанность лежит на говорящем поэтому
восточные люди не умеют говорить прямо
а западные люди не умеют говорить вокруг
да около
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
сейчас мы находимся в таком аутентичном
японском ресторане где подают строго
только японскую еду настоящий местные
японцы
пытаемся пообедать взяли набор из рыбы
основные блюда у нас первое это
соответственно со всеми это сырая рыба
тунец
очень легкая вкусная еда Я просто обожаю
реально вкусно
очень похоже в частности то что
палочками есть наконец-то привычная
удобная посуда и поза для еды нормально
Мне нравится на самом деле для меня все
очень яркое но сидим сегодня полного
погрузить но как кушаем там да это
принципе похоже на казахский стол
национальный и но вкус совершенно другие
поэтому Всем советую присоединять нам
друзья Будьте с нами едите с нами Это
очень сильно заряжает Всем большое
спасибо Привет из Токио
[музыка]
час час
рестораны и закалика
[музыка]
наконец-то Мы приехали в отель
Ну спать хочется
стало
до местность шикарная классная
нравится среди леса Сейчас посмотрим Я
думаю гостиница тоже супер красота очень
красивое место свежий воздух чистый и
чем-то напоминает Боровое
добрались целый день дороги
Сейчас будем располагаться в этом отеле
потом пойдем
купаться Как нам пообещали
[музыка]
помоги Да понятно
мы сейчас находимся в традиционной
японской гостинице сегодня ребята
сходили на горячие источники
это традиционный источник и традиционная
гостиница мы все Решили одеть сегодня
традиционную японскую одежду
юката это вот такое
халат и как Самураи
кайфу хорошо ребята разбудили такую
ответственный момент пришел переоделся в
начале
такие традиции
[смех]
[музыка]
изучаем ее День за днём всё больше и
больше очень интересное впечатляющееся
везде шикарно
Поэтому будем наслаждаться каждыми и у
нас традиционная комната интересна такая
мы будем спать на циновках и у нас ужин
в традиционном японском ресторане вот
так нам накрыли Как вы видите очень все
красиво стильно по-японски очередной
прием пищи
изучаем что какая последовательность
главное не нарушить что зачем сегодня
тоже будет не Первое второе третье Да
Первое второе третье и так далее десятое
инструктаж
проконспектировать что зачем пока Ну
никак кулинарным Узбекистане понимаешь
пока разберешься что зачем откуда
сказали что пока ты не даешь суп тебе не
сваря сейчас подожгли вроде как может
быть чтобы получится
Ждем Теперь когда суп сварится а так все
интересно палками Здесь точно учимся в
общем чтобы Поесть надо напрячься можно
голодным остаться
очень вкусно и необычный вкус такой
очень приятный
но при этом какие-то тонкий вкус у
каждого блюда
и какие-то такие задевает какие-то
глубоко
грибочки очень вкусный как на холодец
наш
[смех]
я все попробовал по чуть-чуть Пока
сильно проголодался у меня уже
приступим
Саша меня
[музыка]
Если вы Прекратите расти как я вчера
говорил то вы сразу же начнете
деградировать вы либо Растете либо
деградируете статического не бывает
залез как на лестницу ступеньку и там
стоишь и можно до конца жизни так не
получится сразу пошла деградация Я
считаю что мир будет цифровой это
неизбежно все к этому идет как здесь
правильно выбрать целый день когда вы
что-то делаете только две вещи то что вы
хотите то что вы должны
вот так проходит наш очередной
[смех]
[аплодисменты]
Итак неудобно всем супер есть
[музыка]
мы получается вчера классно искупались
покушали обалденные в традиционном
ресторане сейчас мы собираемся на
пробежку
очень красивый вид просто Обратите
внимание
[музыка]
как будто оказались решили свернуть
решили прогуляться и кто-то из нас
свернул и мы решили пойти за ним вот
посмотреть этот чудесный лес и ранний
ранний восход в
мне удалось это сказать
[музыка]
Конечно я понял очень красивая страна
холодно конечно
получше Ну это Вся красота
замещает тебе холод это забываешь про
него я уже не жалею что поехал только
начинается
[музыка]
в отлично конечно вообще первый день
немножко
не высыпались Но со второго дня все
устаканилось все нормально
нетворкинги отличные проходят
И вообще природа отличная вообще
[музыка]
бросается их значит специальные ворота
если попадете в круг все обозначено
исполнится Ваше желание
завязать отношения с людьми крепкую
семью построить Если мимо попадете то
тоже ничего страшного значит проложили
усилия То есть хорошо поработали тоже у
вас желание сбудется вот такое верование
[музыка]
загадали желание Да
что творит Давайте вот Виктор заказал
Это я не буду закатывать желание
Выскажите
[музыка]
зеленый шар значит там поставили молодой
Саке и со временем листики начинали
жухнуть высыхать и когда был сухой все
кто проходили Не обязательно было
заходить внутрь можно было посмотреть
далека виде что если зеленые шаримся
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
путешествуем по Японии хайкинг сейчас у
нас Красота натуральная нетронутая
природа чистота идеальна такие подъемы
[смех]
японская кухня идет на пользу мясо не
едим едим только рыбу всё легче и легче
я там внизу видела один листик клёна он
был чуть-чуть отличающийся от этих такой
побольше и супер ярко-красный вот эти
перейду еще такой же а такого же нет да
и очень Широкая палитра цветов классно
красная зеленая желтая смешанная между
собой вообще радует глаз просто
[музыка]
Ура
дошли
[музыка]
шикарные
но есть
не совсем приятная правда для японцев
намного красивее
супер
поднялись на вершину
поняли что там делать нечего для нас
после Килиманджаро там ловить нечего но
и отсюда видно
мы сюда приедем Я загадал думаю
только второй день здесь Поэтому в целом
впечатление пока общая фраза такая
впечатление впечатление три вещи которые
здесь нравится это чистота вежливость
людей и спокойствие
как бы с первого дня то что вот
действительно Вот это какой-то
эмоциональное спокойствие видимо вот
самих японцев Таких вот какая-то
уравновешенность ну воспитанность очень
очень воспитанная люди как бы такая
Атмосфера и очень красивая природа
конечно
[музыка]
идем в первый день обучения сегодня
будем начинаем учиться
Все Зарядки осваивать японские
технологии
[музыка]
пришли как настоящие студенты учиться на
лекцию нормально
[музыка]
последний третьих автомобилей мы
продавались
поэтому они
[музыка]
живущие
осторон модуля нашей встречи
[музыка]
очень много инсайтов уже хочется прям
закатать рукава ехать внедрять это всё
правда По примеру Toyota сказали что у
них заняло 10 лет внедрение Надеюсь у
нас получится перенять опыт немножко
быстрее Как долго не меняли мышление
людей я получил ответ на свой главный
вопрос что меняли мышление людей 10 лет
10 лет и сразу вопрос а мы готовы такой
забег И что надо делать менталитетом
наши сотрудников что вот это вот
Хозяйство у нас внедрить
потому что все то что новое Я пытаюсь
всегда на предприятии втолкать оно
Сквозь слезы через кровь люди уходят не
хотят жить по-новому и так далее так
далее так далее И вот этот вопрос мне
очень сильно волнует и я сейчас понимаю
что они не исключение раз они 10 лет
этим занимались у меня был главный
Инсайт что конечный контроль качества
может быть не нужен потому что я как раз
в компании собирался внедрять контроль
качества Вот а оказывается нужно
прописать алгоритмы и стандарты качества
на каждом из этапе производства и
сделать внедрение на уровне всех
сотрудников чтобы каждый сотрудник перед
тем как передать свою часть работы сам
проверял свою контроль качества делал и
тогда на последующих этапах этот
контроль качества просто не нужен будет
И вот По примеру Toyota Я думаю что мы
будем также делать И дай Бог у нас всё
получится
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
это музей Тойоты Хотим посмотреть здесь
историю и как она развивалась когда сила
сегодняшнее состояние Но это откатский
станок раньше Toyota в начале работала
текстиле там сильное оборудование
производила
[музыка]
здесь мы сейчас находимся вместе где
была первая фабрика тойода то есть
изначально Это был завод по производству
текстиля здесь не было никаких
автомобилей Вот примерно так все
выглядело но Давайте пойдем по очереди
по порядку Вот это бюст основателя
Toyota
и здесь вы видите один из его станков
пожалуй самый знаменитый это так
называемый
автоматический станок модель G А дальше
вы увидите как он на самом деле работает
такие патенты нововведения Toyota на нем
используют
там будут профессиональные гиды которые
прямо покажут как все это делается
[музыка]
а также это станок обладает встроенной
функцией
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
Это первый этот автомобиль который
Тойота стали производить вначале они
собрали
деревянную модель получается
вырезали А уже под нее они стали
подгонять детали и вот на основании вот
этого макета не произвели первую серию
автомобилей марки Toyota
Один который 35 году
[музыка]
мы находимся на заводе Toyota
производства
станков до производства автомобилей и я
что заметил японцы мастера визуализации
мы проходили вот тему визуализацию там
говорили вот нам сегодня важный
визуализировать показывать для
сотрудников наглядно Что видели Так вот
здесь мы увидели что такое визуализация
все детали от двигателя до ходовой части
визуализировано и показано показа
полностью процесс сборки автомобиля от
начала до конца доча супер Используйте
визуализацию она очень помогает
[музыка]
Вот это красота
Привет Меня зовут Артем Я из Казахстана
алма-ата занимаюсь стройкой парков
короче оказался здесь вообще я увидел
рекламу в Инстаграме пришел точнее
увидел рекламу Мне понравилось идея в
эту идею вписался не спал быстро решил
вопрос деньгами пошел оплатил вписался в
эту Движуху и спустя месяц я здесь мы
сегодня побывали в Индустриальном музее
компании Toyota
мы посмотрели как зарождалась компания
Toyota как вообще зарождалась эта
технология мы сегодня были на А в музее
Тойоты мы получили невероятные эмоции
здесь Было очень круто э я увидел
огромный огромный просто масштаб а
человеческой мысли нам только нужно
стремиться к этим людям это культура это
менталитет это отношение к работе
отношение к порядку дисциплине э всё
очень круто начиная от бензиновых они на
сегодня перешли гибридным водородным а
для нас в Казахстане
до сих пор это как бы новое до сих пор
мы такие машины и не знаем но здесь как
бы это в порядке вещей обучение у людей
которые имеют
непосредственное отношение к самой
компании Toyota Конечно мы это все видим
когда я вижу как это все делается Я
понимаю что значит здесь здесь сто
процентов есть то что мы проходили
буквально полтора часа проходили здесь
это явно Четко просто отображено
всю историю
очень важно было посмотреть
чего они начинали и Чем закончились
к этому нужно стремиться их нужно брать
пример история этой компании больше 100
лет и очень интересно наблюдать момент
становления развития этой компании
постараемся применить Это в нашей стране
и будем обучать наших людей поднимать
экономику Нам тоже надо будет
перестраиваться я просто думаю когда
Я надеюсь что все мои восхищения
умиления и удивления они соберутся в
один какой-нибудь такой сосуд и родят
что-то новое на территории нашей страны
Меня интересует экономика нашей страны
здесь я понятно что все хорошо нам нужно
поднимать наша экономику и делать
максимально для нашей страны
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
бетонируют когда они в лёд выходят из
строя то есть очень быстро стирается
разрушается поэтому всегда при
строительстве таких производств нужно
использовать специалистов и
соответствующие технологию заливки полов
Вот именно на производственных
предприятиях независимо от птицеводство
что-то еще какая-то либо
Машиностроительная
[музыка]
отдает его на комплектацию заказа он
должен проверить три поля сравнить Что
они одинаковые во внутренней карточке и
карточкой клиента
Если сотрудник допустит ошибку то
заказчик получит не ту деталь Ну это
большой так сказать проблема в
дальнейшем
[музыка]
создаем себе проблемы
Приятного аппетита всем сели кушать
запах еды
[музыка]
Это что такое
степени
хочешь не только есть
это Смотри куда рыба еще внутри рыбы
есть классно
прекрасно отношусь особенно вкусной
японской кухне её можно делить тоже
наверное на разные но сюда мы пришли
прямо пробовать особо крутые деликатесы
например смотрите
3-4 вида разные рыбы и вся полностью
сырая вообще у нас сырую рыбу мало кто
есть но здесь это считается прям Элита
[музыка]
вы чувствуете этот запах это просто
невероятно Япония удивляет каждый днем
все больше и больше я не знаю мне
кажется эти впечатления никогда не
закончатся
супер
это Япония
здесь такая технология сами жарь как бы
Сам проверяй и сам кушай
необычно
кушайте
обожаю такую еду
теперь в Алмате
В общем вы поняли
застоявшийся успешный бизнесмен
богатый бизнес
продал сейчас он живет очень простой
жизни небольшой домик велосипед
2-3 комплекта одежды и максимум поэтому
сегодня в пол специально приехал с Киото
познакомиться
что ему большое спасибо
[музыка]
45 минут пятиминутные процессы за две
недели
и мой стартап стал бизнесом года
[аплодисменты]
Евгений криптовалютный гений
Добрый день готовимся ехать на Чемпионат
сумо и потом летим в Токио или Мы
сначала летим в Токио потом на Чемпионат
свой Я не совсем понял
короче на Чемпионат сома будем смотреть
как эти большие японцы друг друга
обнимают и кайфуют от этого
город ну-ка назови
кока-сока
Мы едем город Коко Ока на Чемпионате
мы сегодня покидаем короче город ногой
Всё мы говорим пока едем на чемпионат
мира ногой было классно Но должна
порадовать нас больше потому что там
будет более
Entertainment У нас тут мы какие-то
заводы так учёба там будет уже
развлечение тусовочки поэтому готовимся
тоже классно отдохнуть посмотреть Японию
с другой стороны
[музыка]
Да
когда последний раз выходили строем с
детским лагерем и парами
строим Последний раз
я не помню
наверное в детском саду
а может а может в лагере Может в лагере
ходили в каком лагере
едем к моим братьям старшим они намного
больше потому что они телом так
покрупнее будут будем смотреть с ума
с детства
мечтал попасть на сумо
Ну если я так сказал был бы эффект на
самом деле никогда не думал об этом
сегодня будет Чемпионат по сумму Вот мы
будем едем чтобы болеть за него
в Японии полных людей вообще нету
[смех]
на 16 платформе у нас там поезд на зомби
21 на всякий случай
Мы сегодня проедем на скоростном поезде
700 километров за три часа
[музыка]
блин это другая планета реально это так
такого Мы никогда не видели это скоро
этот пояс есть со скоростью 500
километров в час на минуточку 500
километров в час Ну у него есть
остановки же это максимальная скорость
500 километров в час
а так у него средняя скорость он
получается посчитали где-то около 300 км
Вот кстати он разгоняется
[музыка]
первый раз японском поезде очень мягко
все
удобно Здесь даже
Мы едем со скоростью 280 километров в
час
пока еще не разогнались Пользуясь
случаем хочу передать привет всем своим
17 миллионам подписчиков
просто Казахстан
у тех у кого есть телефоны на самом деле
архитектура
небольшие дома в ряд идеальное
расположение домов
и природа
задействован каждый кусочек земли
практически нет здесь пустых территорий
всё задействовано либо выращивать рис
либо какие-то другие культуры и
либо постройки или дороги нету пустой
земли вообще нет
кайдзен это сила конфетку
[музыка]
Сегодня мы идем на просмотр
распространенного в Японии борьбы
единоборства сумо
в ожидании в ожидании Я надеюсь там
будет самый самый здоровый японец чтобы
с ним сфотографироваться очень классно А
еще один случай у нас сегодня произошел
кстати поезде скоростном поезде один из
участников
В итоге обратились в администрацию
вокзала сумочка уже была
в администрации этого вокзала и быстро
вернули Вот что значит культура в Япония
в целом
Другой мир как я говорил ранее
наконец-то мы запомнили что мы уока
будем смотреть Чемпионат
Чемпионат мира по сумо Я думаю что это
будет интересно я первый раз жизни
буду видеть
в живую этих людей
огромные массы начинается
минимум 160 максимум 250 килограммов
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
вторая часть дня соревнования где
остались сильнейшие бойцы сейчас будут
выступать самые сильнейшие сумоисты и мы
будем за этим наблюдать Если обратить
внимание сейчас стали уже такие все
увесистые 150 кг выше все такие бойцы
очень интересно
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
Мне нравится шоу между боями только что
я проморгал один бой
Вот так повернуть
Артём тебе да все расскажет Он лучше
знает чем чем они самый сейчас будет
король короче сейчас будет бороться тот
родной за который я начал смотреть сумму
либо не горгаза ну японское имя Татьяна
Син мы сейчас наблюдаем получается
борцов высокого уровня где-то средних Ну
как типа как КМС
это магазин серы они делятся вам
Западный магазин Восточный магазин
смотрите получается почему зал не полный
вроде бы это очень крутой интересный
спорт для японцев но все песни что
турнир проходит 15 дней
не всегда бывает полная самый полный зал
всегда это первый день и в 15 день когда
уже финальный финальный
Когда уже награждение будет кубок
императора разыгрывается по-моему
разыгрывается
Наверное я люблю то что это очень
красивый вид спорта без грязи без таких
каких-то моментов и тут невозможно если
ты сильно у тебя система выталкивает
автоматически Так что вот такие вот дела
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
все время это были Киото
Это неделя занятий в Киото такое
ощущение как будто мы в Японии уже месяц
находимся Мы были в Токио приехали такое
ощущение как будто это было когда-то
давно
вот такие эмоции
[смех]
[музыка]
Мы приехали в баню Это я сейчас вам
париться вообще хочу
Да ничего страшного короче
И поэтому
ты подошел сюда Что тебе нравится твой
первое впечатления культура
аутентичность то что здесь очень
стилизовано Если бы я зашел в такую баню
в Казахстане в нашу казану казахскую
баню традиционную кто-то бы это придумал
Было бы очень круто когда я посещаю
такие места
я больше сейчас смотрю не на Не напарда
потому что печку затопите там дров
накидать может каждый А я больше смотрю
на Entertainment на организацию всего
этого процесса и Чем интереснее
entertainmen чем интереснее сама
короче упаковка тем лучше тот кто
сделает крутую упаковку в бизнесе в
любом не важно В каком В частности мы в
бане Кто здесь крутую баню тот будет
очень крутой очень крутой и она чтобы
понимали Кстати как предприниматель
скажу 40% маржинальность этого бизнеса
потому что вы продаете по сути пар 40
процентов маржа и на кухне
продавать в зависимости Меня зовут рынка
[музыка]
японские бани это что-то необычное
интересное и непохожие ничто другое мы
находимся в термальных источниках в
центре Токио вода идет прям из-под Земли
с природными минералами после такого
длинного
перелета там на автобусе ездили
сегодня еще на заводах были сегодня
вот
Relax Time очень полезно Это прям
идеальное завершение сегодняшнего вечера
Она состоит из множества бассейнов с
горящими источниками Кстати мы были там
чуть дальше а там прям есть отдельный
источник про Он пробурин немного глубже
и там совершенно другие минералы
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
работать
никуда не посмотришь все оптимизировано
короче умеет делать все в принципе и
работать максимально и отдыхать
максимально
[музыка]
когда девушка
[аплодисменты]
[музыка]
мы замеряем процесс сборки одной детали
то есть пытаемся на производстве выявить
время такта и хотим понять Сколько
времени уходит на сборку этой детали
причем Это нужно делать не торопясь
чтобы все детали собирались качественные
чего по пути не развалилось поэтому
здесь очень важный момент собрать
правильно не нужно делать на скорость
нужно делать на качество
здесь задача чтобы за 5 секунд сделать
Один трактор Весь процесс но получается
что мы все одновременно будем собирать
каждый каждую запчасть по 5 секунд на
три этапа один ноги делает другую на
голову одевает каску
а третий вставляет Вот это если нужно в
две секунды укладывать
[музыка]
на американских автозаводах менеджмент
всегда говорил сотрудникам что вы
шестеренки в нашем механизме
И вам достаточно лишь выполнять
распоряжение руководства
думать ни о чем не надо
сотрудника сознает что руководитель не
контролирует его процесс будь то
производство
бизнес-процесса он начинает писать цифры
которые реальность не отражают
Вот почему нам нужно
месту по факту
[музыка]
просто Хаус в голове вот так вот
забросили у тебя ты не поймешь там
откуда что А сейчас вот когда начинаешь
общаться оттуда это Слышишь У тебя
начинает в голове это все
систематизироваться я все время куда-то
вперед стремился то с чем-то боролся
своей жизни Потом когда уже заработал
много денег я в какой-то невесомости
оказался в какой-то невесомости где я
грубо говоря не знал что дальше делать Я
два года грубо говоря ходил блуждал пока
не пришел вот на встречу
здесь я как раз таки для себя открыл что
в принципе есть такое направление жизни
в принципе Оказывается можно жизнь
именно тратить таким образом Да
по-другому есть вот такой вот допустим
круг общения такие люди единомышленники
пришел к тому что теперь у меня еще в
голове это все началось
систематизироваться все это у нас в
голове было просто не было порядка не
было кайдзена в нашей голове
[музыка]
не на самом деле для меня поездка первую
очередь означала две недели сам собой
уединение в такой прекрасной атмосфере
конечно же всегда приятно путешествовать
и людьми кто окружает его потому что это
все Энергичные как правило дающие люди
соответственно тебя отдых получается на
высочайшем уровне А еще точно обучение
же если я забыл
TPS ещё есть
но это было приятно наполнением лично
для меня
[музыка]
[аплодисменты]
мы на смотровой площадке в центре Токио
Вот посмотрите как Токио выглядит
например под нами
страшно густонаселенный город конечно
Просто нереально населенное
[музыка]
отлично А я даже не смотрел еще
фотографировался
Да классный вид вообще шикарный чудесно
мы находимся на 52 этаже
какого-то бизнес-центра по-моему
прекрасным видом
[музыка]
наконец-то идет дождь Токийский дождь мы
попали под него он такой Мелкий и в
принципе такой приятный дождик
не напрягает вообще
Как наш Алматинский Весенний дождь
Классно же свежо зелень и такой Озон
Воздух очень интересно деревья промокают
и выделяют чувствуется запах
этот запах такой прям шикарный и через
камеру не передать
[музыка]
никогда не понимал современное искусство
никогда не нравилось это современное
искусство да это
крутое завершение нашей программы
финальный красивый аккорд особенно когда
лежа там я не знаю я я хочу вообще
комнату
[музыка]
отправляй кругосветное путешествие у нас
возле Токио потоки потом Тихий океан
может оттуда на Сахалин рванем Посмотрим
по ситуации как получится я как говорил
как карты лягут нам
еды хватит Надеюсь Вау
интересно за месяц
[музыка]
хорошо хорошо
Ну что ребята подошла наша поездка к
концу вроде бы казалось что слишком
долго Но вот последний день уже и не
хочется как-то уезжать мы завершаем нашу
поездку
улетаем домой получено много инсайтов
сегодня улетаем радости полные штаны
если честно
попасть такое окружение и я в него
попала ни капельки об этом не жалею Я
ожидал получить меньше
первое
Японии но это было очень давно 2003 году
сейчас конечно другими глазами Япония
если честно ощущение как будто давно уже
живешь в Японии на третий день уже
считают что как будто месяц там или два
и даже больше как будто так и надо все
моя основная цель поездки в Японию
во-первых перенять опыт у японцев
увидеть изнутри то есть изначально узнав
что такое кайз мне захотелось побывать в
той стране Откуда
идут истоки Именно этого это их
отношение к жизни отношение к людям мир
личностные отношения к природе они
реально показывают что нет ничего
невозможного
эффективно работы ты можешь достичь
невероятных ребята ребята ушли очень
далеко в своем подходе к жизни к своим
отношениям И вообще
то есть очень очень простые ответы на
сложные вопросы у них уже такая культура
я такую в Алмате только вижу
среди тех кто любит горы ходить
люди всегда тоже мусор с собой забирают
в пакетах до города и потом выкидывает
его философию кайдзена она единая и то
что марган Калиевич сейчас внедряет в
наши умы в создает уроки это все
напрямую связано с философией кальцем и
они настолько любят свое дело настолько
вот готовы его делать от и до
погружаясь скажем так детали что
нам работать
моя еще более чем скажем так успешно у
нас получилось очень шикарная компания
очень много интересных позитивных людей
Давно я не встречал может быть даже в
первый раз жизни
[музыка]
говорят знаешь не важно куда важно с кем
Да все было замечательно
[музыка]
полная энергия заряженные Будем дальше
работать над кайзеном
желание есть учиться
несмотря на возраст учиться хочется Век
живи век учись один говорят
надо учиться хорошо то что хорошо
заканчивается поэтому все заканчивается
круто поездка прошла на ура энергия прёт
Как из атомной электростанции Вот это у
меня такое сейчас я до сих пор не знаю
как следующий раз вернуться в Японию и
получить то же самое что мы получили
сейчас пока решение
[музыка]
Желаю вам такого же путешествуйте друзья
наслаждайтесь любите жизнь кайфуйте
[музыка]